sur le revenu une fois de plus le
télescope hubble pourtant menacée nous
prouve qu'il est capable d'aller
toujours plus loin dans la connaissance
de l'univers grâce à lui des
scientifiques ont pu observer la galaxie
la plus éloignée et donc aussi la plus
anciennes découvertes à ce jour nicolas
chateauneuf trois petits arcs rouge
difficiles à identifier
mais qui sont en fait trois reflet d'une
seule et même galaxie la plus lointaine
jamais observée
tellement lointaine que sa lumière a mis
13 milliards d'années pour nous parvenir
et encore déformés et amplifié par
d'autres galaxies placé sur son chemin
un effet de loupe qui nous permet de
plonger 13 milliards d'années en arrière
à cette époque la terre n'existait même
pas et les étoiles éclairé depuis peu
notre univers
ça nous permet de voir comment se sont
formés les galaxies comment étaient les
galaxies il ya 13 milliards d'années et
petit à petit en en allant de plus en
plus loin de d'essayer de comprendre
comment l'univers s'est formé une
découverte réalisée par une équipe
internationale grâce au télescope
spatial hubble menaçait de retraite
anticipée par la nasa le satellite est
pourtant à l'origine de presque une
avancée par semaine la dernière concerne
osiris une planète extrasolaire chez
laquelle une équipe française a décelé
du carbone et de l'oxygène son
atmosphère est littéralement soufflée
par les trois voisines
un scénario catastrophe qu'a sans doute
connu notre terre dans sa prime jeunesse